all right amid those growing protests in
various states against stay-at-home
orders the Attorney General is weighing
in on the restrictions stemming from the
pandemic we're looking carefully at a
number of these rules that are being put
into place and if we think one goes too
far we initially try to jawbone the
governor's and to rolling them back or
adjusting them and if they're not and
people bring to us as we file statement
of interest and and side with the
plaintiffs as lawsuits develop as
specific cases emerge in the states
we'll take a look at them joining us now
is Ian Pryor he's a former deputy
director of public affairs at the
Department of Justice
Ian we appreciate you coming in thanks
for having me the Attorney General
William bar weighing in there Chris
Wallace was on last hour saying it's he
believed that it was shaky legal ground
the Attorney General was on and he
didn't quite understand why he was
weighing it at all how do you how do you
answer that well I think what the
Attorney General is doing here is he's
not necessarily saying that any one
thing is in is onerous or not but then
we are in sort of times that we have not
seen probably since World War two where
a lot of these restrictions are
certainly going to be burdens on civil
rights not just because something is a
burden on a civil right doesn't mean
it's unconstitutional and just because
the state does something to protect
people doesn't mean it is constitutional
so what the Attorney General is doing is
saying I'm gonna look at these
restrictions and you know if something
starts to go over what we think is the
constitutional line we're gonna try and
talk to the municipality or the state
and if that doesn't work and somebody
brings a lawsuit we'll will look at
weighing in well I wonder though if he's
tipped his hand a bit in terms of where
he stands on this and in terms of the
pendulum and how its swinging because he
said it was close to house arrest in
this radio interview with you you and
take a listen to what the Attorney
General said the idea that you have to
stay in your house is disturbingly close
to house arrest I'm not saying it wasn't
justified and not saying in some places
it might be still justified but it's a
very onerous as is shutting down your
livelihood this is something that we've
seen with protests around the country
but to say it's close to house arrest
when it's something that the president
the
Whitehouse said maybe reluctantly but
they had to do because it was a health
crisis yeah this is actually interesting
and these these stories should be used
in constitutional law classes throughout
the country for the next 50 years yeah I
think what we have to look at is when we
have things like house arrest is it the
most narrowly tailored solution that's
the constitutional test and in some
cases it may be and I think that's what
the Attorney General is saying in some
cases perhaps not leaving your house is
the most narrowly tailored solution we
can get to preventing the spread of
coronavirus which is a compelling
government interest so maybe in a place
like you know a highly dense place where
people are leaving their house that's
not such a great thing but if you're in
Wyoming for instance or a rural area is
that really the most narrowly tailored
solution to this compelling government
interest and I think that's where you
have to look at it you have to see is
this something that is actually helping
the situation or is it too broad in its
application in very many chances it
could be it depends on the circumstance
surface of whether it's too broad in the
last 30 seconds we have maybe the
Attorney General had a point because as
we just reported a moment ago the
Michigan governor under pressure is now
saying yeah maybe some of it went too
far and she's pulling back yeah
absolutely and perhaps what what bar did
effectively there was communicate you're
not necessarily a threat but a warning
that every government every state
government or city in town really needs
to look at these restrictions and make
sure that they pass constitutional
muster
I'm sure the federal okay is not
involved in kids in this or intervening
in lawsuits but the fact is they have a
job to protect the Constitution and so
they need to make sure that all the
municipalities are doing their job as
well in Prior thank you